get excited nene leakes might be
returning to the Real Housewives of
Atlanta for good after being a full-time
housewife for years the outspoken
reality star took on a smaller role this
past season NeNe Leakes is not just a
reality star I am a mogul I am an
actress budget fear not Atlanta fans
because et has learned we might be
getting a whole lot more Nene it's gonna
be really great a source close to the 48
year-old tells ET exclusively it
wouldn't be a surprise if she came back
in some capacity that door is definitely
still open the same source added that
none of the current land housewives are
officially confirmed to return for
season nine yet but said they wouldn't
be surprised to see me back old time EG
recently spoke with Nene's co-star
Cynthia Bailey who opened up about the
possibility of Nene's full-time return
to the show that made her famous do you
think she'll be back full-time next
season you know I don't know I don't
know I had dinner with her the other
night I think she's open I think she's
open to you know she's a lot of things
coming with you know but I think there's
something about her coming in and out at
least is that's kind of nice one face we
definitely won't be seeing next season
it Kim feel the facts of life star
revealed earlier this week she's
departing the show for good after just
one season
you